bonjour François Bayrou bonjour Emmanuel
Macron s'adresse aux Français tout à
l'heure mais il a déjà prévenu qu'il
n'annoncera ni dissolution ni
remaniement ni référendum sur les
retraites qu'est-ce qui lui reste du
coup elle lui reste deux choses très
importantes alors tout le monde a repris
ni
dissolution ni remaniement ni référendum
je veux dire ce sont des armes que le
Président de la République en 5e
République a dans sa main mais j'imagine
que c'est pas pour les utiliser
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas des
c'est pas des réponses de cette alors
qu'est-ce qu'il a d'autres il a deux
impératifs le premier de ces impératifs
c'est rassurer les Français sur la
nécessité absolue de la réforme
que au fond le président de la
République a dit hier quelque chose que
je partage profondément il a dit on n'a
pas réussi à faire partager aux Français
les raisons de très fort c'est un
euphémisme oui on peut on peut aussi
dire comme ça et donc et donc ce
[Musique]
cette mission du président de la
République et de partager avec les
citoyens qui l'ont élu avec les Français
au fond le fond de cette affaire le fond
de cette démarche pourquoi et vous savez
que je me suis beaucoup exprimé sur ce
sujet pourquoi parce que les
déséquilibres dont on n'a pas parlé et
je n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi on
en a pas parlé et déséquilibres
financiers du système de retraite
français qui les paye et ben c'est les
générations à venir parce que c'est
déséquilibre entre 30 et 40 milliards
par an au moins 30 milliards de déficits
on les paye par la dette et ça on va
détailler tout ça
il est vrai alors il est vrai que que
beaucoup n'en parlent pas pour des
raisons que
je ne comprends pas bien tout ça mais
vous dites premier point était justifié
qui va continuer à rassurer sur le fond
de la réforme deuxième point et
deuxièmement il doit replacer l'action
du gouvernement l'action de l'exécutif
ça volonté en tant que président de la
République dans un cadre plus large et
plus projeté vers l'avenir parler de la
suite par les autres choses que des
retraites pas d'autres choses
sans la réforme des retraites plus rien
n'était possible pendant un temps
certain
c'était une c'était une situation de
blocage serait été une situation de
blocage sans issue
mais il est vrai que la campagne
présidentielle c'est à mes yeux
un peu limité ou n'a abordé que cette
question de la réforme des retraites
alors qu'il y a la grande question du
projet national des des grands enjeux et
du modèle de société française
c'est ça qui est en péril nous avons un
modèle
dans le pays vous voyez bien ce qui se
passe dehors dans les rues tous les
soirs si Emmanuel Macron arrive tout à
l'heure à 13h en disant en fait vous
avez pas tout à fait compris ce qu'on
voulait faire parce que on l'a mal
expliqué sans doute mais vous pensez que
ça va passer vous pensez que
comment dire
quelque chose est vital pour un peuple
il est du devoir des responsables de le
conduire à son terme en l'expliquant je
trouve que cette partie explication a
été un tout petit peu oublié et laisser
ce côté
de l'autoflagellation il est le
président de la République il est en
charge vous voyez bien qu'il n'y a
aucune autre majorité disponible
et donc il a la responsabilité
de partager avec les Français les
raisons profondes de tout ça et la
raison profonde et première et de
justice et d'équité c'est qu'on peut pas
continuer à surcharger les générations
qui viennent vous reconnaîtrez un thème
que j'ai beaucoup défendu avec une dette
qu'ils vont devoir assumer en plus de
leurs conditions de travail en plus des
nécessités de la société dans laquelle
nous vivons ceci est une injustice grâce
et devant laquelle
les générations qui en profitent
devraient être honteuses faire payer les
plus jeunes à long terme pour les
boomers c'est c'est comme on dit c'est
moralement inacceptable parce que la
situation politique aujourd'hui François
Bayrou elle est catastrophique hier à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était les
questions au Gouvernement et Mathilde
panot la chef de fil des insoumis s'est
adressée à Elisabeth Elisabeth borne la
première ministre écoutait madame la
Première ministre vous céderez
vous céderez car vous ne tenez qu'à 9
voix
vous aiderez car de Français sur 3 soit
votre départ vous céderez car passer en
force contre le peuple les syndicats le
Parlement relève d'une folie vous
céderez et au moment où vous céderez il
sera déjà trop tard car votre de votre
pouvoir il ne restera que des débris
est-ce qu'un gouvernement reste légitime
quand il a failli être renversé à neuf
fois après
s'il avait été renversé
même à une voix bah il aurait quitté ses
fonctions la démocratie vous savez la
République
a été votée à une voix
et heureusement elle s'est imposée elle
est légitime c'est c'est comme ça que la
démocratie fonctionne alors c'est serré
la démocratie et là en l'occurrence ça
l'était mais si c'est serré la
démocratie est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas
fallu faire preuve de panache et de
soumettre la loi retraite au vote des
députés pour qu'on se compte pour que
vous vous comptiez pour qu'on voit s'il
y avait une majorité aujourd'hui pour
réformer ou non le système
ce sont des questions qui ont été
abordées par les fondateurs de la
Cinquième République et même avant eux
par ceux qui ont essayé de sauver la
Quatrième République financé
ou non cette loi oui mais heureusement
le 49 ce qu'on appelle le 40 9.3
connaissez diaboliser parce que on est
stupide parce que on est ignorant la
plupart du temps on a laissé diaboliser
une une disposition essentielle de la
Constitution qui est celle-ci le
gouvernement vient devant les députés et
dit voilà ce projet est
vital pour le pays et pour ma vision de
l'avenir si ce projet ne peut pas être
adopté alors je n'ai plus rien je n'ai
plus de légitimité il vient
et on remet au député le vote suprême
c'est-à-dire le sort du gouvernement
ceci a été voulu par
toute la Quatrième République finissante
quand ils en pouvaient plus de voir
exploser le Parlement comme là le
général de Gaulle qui a un vote sur le
texte sur la réforme des retraites
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron a pas fait
preuve de l'acheter non en aucune
manière d'abord c'est pas lui c'est le
49-3 c'est le gouvernement qu'il demande
ce n'est pas Emmanuel Macron
le Président c'est la première ministre
le président de la République a essayé
jusqu'au bout de rassembler un nombre
suffisant de voix mais pour moi
quand vous remettez aux députés le sort
d'un gouvernement fous leur donner le
pouvoir le plus important le pouvoir
maximum parce que les députés à ce
moment-là répondent
oui nous considérons que ce nous
acceptons que ce texte soit pour vous
essentiel et c'est ce qui s'est passé
alors à neuf voix ben ça prouve que les
institutions que nous avons acceptent le
pluralisme pour une fois ça c'est pas
produit souvent François Bayrou au
commissaire au Plan président du MoDem
et maire de Pau et l'invité de France
Info jusqu'à 9h le fil info à 8h41 avec
Maureen sugar
de nouvelles actions en cours en ce
moment contre la réforme des retraites
impossible d'entrer à Marseille via la
55 des manifestants ont allumé des feux
de palettes sur la route la grève se
poursuit aussi dans les raffineries
Total énergie les expéditions sont
arrêtées 12% des stations services
manquent d'au moins un carburant sur
l'ensemble du territoire
peuvent être les mots d'Emmanuel Macron
alors que la réforme a été adoptée avec
le 49-3 interview du chef de l'État à
13h c'est à suivre en direct sur France
Info des hier le chef de l'État parlait
devant les parlementaires de son compte
la foule qui manifeste n'a pas de
légitimité face au peuple qui s'exprime
à travers ses élus dit Emmanuel Macron
réaction ce matin du président du groupe
les républicains à l'Assemblée nationale
le rôle du président c'est de chercher à
apaiser pas de donner le sentiment de
jeter de l'huile sur le feu dit Olivier
marlex des attaques de drones russes
touchent l'Ukraine ce matin trois morts
à Kiev selon les autorités locales
Moscou dénonce de son côté des attaques
sur le port de Sébastopol en Crimée
[Musique]
France Info
le 8 30 France Info Samia brachia Marc
fauvelde
François Bayrou la loi on l'a dit la loi
je vous écoute
réponse ouais la loi est adoptée on l'a
dit grâce aux 49-3 mais est-ce que vous
conseillez à Emmanuel Macron d'attendre
avant de la promulguer le temps que ça
se calme dans le pays franchement on a
des souvenirs comme ça Jacques Chirac
avait fait un choix suspension du CPE et
ça n'est jamais remis pour dire la
vérité donc le cheminement normal on
n'est pas la promulgation je cheminement
normal c'est que le texte a été adopté
ou est réputé adopté et que maintenant
il part au Conseil constitutionnel il
peut reconseille constitutionnel avec
deux questions qui sont posées autour de
ce texte la première c'est est-ce que on
peut imposer un référendum sur ce texte
tout de suite
en principe la loi dit qu'il faut non
mais il y a une question qui est posée
sur ce référendum d'initiative partagée
avec des citoyens il y a une deuxième
solution pardon vous y seriez favorable
non je vous dirai si vous voulez
deuxième question sur la validité de la
sur le texte est-ce qu'il est-ce que ces
dispositions sont constitutionnelles
est-ce que son adoption a été
constitutionnelle et là il y a un mois
non j'ai aucune crainte sur rien quand
on quand vous êtes absolument certain
que
il y a des menaces sur le pays et qu'on
peut les a et qu'on doit les affronter
on aurait pu les affronter différemment
je j'avais d'autres idées je les ai
défendues longtemps sur sur le texte des
retraites mais il demeure que
aujourd'hui
il y a péril en la demeure si on ne fait
rien et donc je comprends très bien le
la démarche qui est qui a été suivi même
si je crois oui en effet on aurait pu
faire autrement et notamment on aurait
pu associer les Français à la réflexion
sur ce sujet donc voilà
donc on n'est pas à la promulgation la
promulgation c'est une fois que le
Conseil constitutionnel a rendu une
décision en disant ceci est
constitutionnel et ceci ne l'est pas et
sur le référendum d'initiative partagé
c'est pas une solution pour sortir de la
crise non je
j'ai défendu beaucoup l'idée que la
réforme des retraites devait être
adoptée par référendum ça fait 15 ans 20
ans mais plus que j'ai défendu mais la
réforme des retraites elle est là
c'était une démarche complètement
différente et on peut pas changer la pas
été votée par l'Assemblée nationale et
elle a non je suis en désaccord avec
vous elle a été adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale suite au 49-3 oui mais quand
même c'est une dispositions essentielles
regarde s'en est servi 28 fois je crois
dans mon souvenir c'était presque plus
parce qu'on avait l'impression que
c'était tout le temps
28 fois vous allez pas dire que cet
anticonstitutionnel j'ai pas dit ça
c'est le chacun des parlementaires
on se nomme et conscience c'est vu
remettre la décision suprême est-ce que
étant donné ce texte vous renversez le
gouvernement où vous acceptez que le
gouvernement continue avec ce texte
comment on peut faire plus plus chargé
de signification pour pour un vote
parlementaire François Bayrou la foule
n'a pas de légitimité face au peuple qui
s'exprime à travers ses élus et c'est ce
qu'elle dit Emmanuel Macron hier soir
face à ces troupes face aux députés et
sénateurs de la majorité est-ce que
c'est un dérapage ou un bras d'honneur
comme le dis ce matin le rassemblement
national
les mots dans ces dans ces périodes sont
facilement excessifs est-ce que c'est le
casque ils le sont excessif moi je
n'aurais pas dit les choses comme ça je
vais le dire comme je les aurais dites
pas chacun je dirige un débat sur la fin
de vie et c'était très très intéressant
chacun a sa légitimité
les manifestations ont leur légitimité
mais ça n'est pas une légitimité
supérieure à la légitimité démocratique
la Constitution je vous rappelle dit la
souveraineté appartient au peuple qu'il
exerce au travers de ses représentants
et donc
c'est de la
constitutions
les souvenirs
littérature c'est Victor Hugo cette
grande cette distinction entre la foule
et le peuple suffit d'ailleurs de ce
remettre devant les yeux ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis avec les partisans
de Trump qui ont essayé de prendre le
Capitole où était la légitimité est-ce
que c'était dans la foule qui a ça y est
le Capitole et qui voulait renverser où
est-ce que c'était dans les institutions
des États-Unis d'Amérique et par les
représentants qui nous arrivent la même
chose non pas du tout je j'illustre il a
le président de la République a eu une
formule la mienne est un peu différente
il a eu cette formule mais je donne
l'illustration de cette formule lorsque
ils ont attaqué le Capitole c'était une
foule mais elle n'avait pas la
légitimité des institutions et donc il
faut il faut trouver cet équilibre là
mais pour ma part je ne n'irai pas
la légitimité des manifestations quelque
chose
s'exprime qui est très important pour
les pour les gens qui qui viennent là
c'est pour moi le
symptôme de cette incommunicabilité dans
laquelle on se trouve entre le
les pouvoirs officiels et les citoyens
de base ça fait plusieurs décennies ça
fait peut-être 30 ans 40 ans qu'on est
dans ce cette espèce de mur de verre et
c'est ce mur de verre qu'il faut faire
sauter en tout cas c'est ça qui
m'intéresse moi François Bayrou on n'a
pas beaucoup vu et pas beaucoup entendu
Édouard Philippe ces dernières semaines
il donne ce matin une interview est-ce
que vous trouvez que c'est normal qu'un
ex Premier ministre qui est l'un des
piliers avec vous de la majorité avec
son parti horizon
ne défende pas la réforme comme d'autres
moi je
je donne pas de leçons
aux gens avec qui je me bats avec qui
vous vous battez oui
sont pas toujours d'une chaleur extrême
on se trompe ah bon nous avons été sur
des lignes politiques différentes et
même très différentes
et
sur l'air traite il a fait le job c'est
pas planqué qui simulait ça c'est ça
c'est des ce sont des appréciations ils
étaient une question il a fait le job il
se il s'est exprimé il s'exprime
aujourd'hui encore
et
simplement il a pris la distance qu'il
lui est apparu légitime et en tout cas
moi j'ai
j'irai à son congrès samedi ou à sa
réunion samedi
parce que je trouve que dans la majorité
je dirais ma mot de là de la majorité on
est co-responsable de l'avenir on a
chacun à sa place on tient une des clés
de ce que cet avenir doit être quand il
doit Philippe et nous et
en marche Renaissance
chacun a sa place et ses clés et moi
j'ai un mot quand il dit ce matin
justement qu'il faut étendre la majorité
macroniste à gauche aux élus de gauche
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec la nuque
vous êtes d'accord avec lui le
quinquennat doit se recentrer un peu
j'ai c'est drôle que comme question en
fait quoi parce que le
on vient d'essayer d'élargir vers les ça
n'a pas vraiment marché ah ça a marché
quand même il y a du groupe qui vote
l'amour
renverser les abdos
vous savez bien que je partage pas cette
expression c'est ni un succès ni une
victoire c'est simplement c'est
simplement le le l'issue d'une période
de tension très difficile l'issue
institutionnelle après il reste l'issue
dans le
dans le peuple on a essayé d'élargir
vers les républicains il y en a 40
d'entre eux qui n'ont pas voté la
censure c'est quand même Paris
40 députés de l'opposition élue dans
l'opposition qui ont dit non nous ne
voulons pas renverser le gouvernement
travaux mettez-vous
je sais bien on caricature à grand trait
mettez-vous à leur place son fait élire
dans l'opposition souvent contre des
candidats qui soutenaient le
gouvernement et au moment de la réforme
la plus difficile donc un populaire ils
font l'effort et moi je leur engrais il
faut l'effort de ne pas renverser le
gouvernement de dire non ça n'est pas un
sujet légitime pour renverser le
gouvernement alors il y en a 19 qui ont
voté la censure c'est tout ça ça fait ça
fait des vagues en interne et c'est
beaucoup en effet mais je n'ai pas envie
de parler légèrement de sujets qui j'en
suis sûr dont j'en suis sûr ils les ont
vécu avec
tension intérieure aussi on poursuit
dans un instinct avec vous François Baro
8h52 le fil info Maurice Seignard
il n'y a pas eu d'arrestation préventive
va sur France Info le préfet de police
de Paris une cinquantaine d'arrestations
dans la capitale hier soir la Défenseur
des droits se dit préoccuper et inquiète
vis-à-vis de ces interpellations la
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites se poursuit des rassemblements
tous les soirs depuis l'utilisation du
49-3 dans plusieurs villes françaises
interview du président de la République
à 13h à suivre en direct sur France Info
aujourd'hui nouvelle journée de
mobilisation nationale à l'appel des
syndicats demain la SNCF prévient le
trafic sera très perturbé les détails
seront donnés à 17h cet après-midi à
Paris il a RATP annonce que plusieurs
lignes de métro seront ouvertes mais
seulement aux heures de pointe et dans
ce contexte difficile pour le
gouvernement on apprend que le projet de
loi immigration ne sera pas examiné
comme prévu la semaine prochaine au
Sénat examen un reporté de ce projet
phare de l'exécutif qui ne fixe pas de
nouvelles dates la plateforme ouvre dans
moins de 10 minutes maintenant pour
postuler pour devenir bénévole aux Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 il faut être
majeur au 1er janvier prochain et être
disponible au moins 10 jours les
bénévoles accueillent les spectateurs et
aident aussi à l'installation de
certains équipements sportifs
France Info
le 8 30 France Info sallya brachia Marc
Fauvel François Bayrou nouvelle journée
de mobilisation demain à l'appel de
l'intersyndical est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron doit tendre la main au syndicat
est-ce qu'il va recevoir Laurent Berger
de la CFDT Philippe Martinez de la CGT
alors qu'il a refusé on s'appelle
quelques jours je trouve que ça serait
bien au stade où nous sommes il faut
retisser les fils il faut retrouver le
contact et le dialogue alors
naturellement c'est mieux si on a en
tête un scénario de
d'issue de crise mais dans les jours qui
viennent ou les semaines qui viennent
oui il faudra que le que le fil soit
renoué avec
les partenaires sociaux mais pas pour
parler des retraites pour parler d'autre
chose non mais on parle que quand vous
recevez quelqu'un vous imposez pas le
sujet de conversation ainsi si vous me
recevez je suis sûr que c'est vous qui
posez les questions et que donc de ce
point de vue là mais ça vous et il vous
a dit quoi on pense qui sait ce que je
pense oui mais dis donc non non
s'il avait ouvert pendant le processus
parlementaire une négociation avec des
organisations syndicales ça voulait dire
que ce qui se passait à l'Assemblée
n'avait plus aucun sens et donc la
logique des choses a été respectée et je
crois que ça serait bien qu'on renoue
les fils on apprend ce matin que ce qui
devait être la prochaine grande loi du
quinquennat la loi sur l'immigration qui
devait arriver devant Le Mans dans
quelques jours la fameuse loi en même
temps qui était censée séduire à la fois
la droite et la gauche est reportée
souhaitez-vous qu'elle soit enterrée non
je pense que c'est un grand sujet
d'inquiétude pour les Français de
d'inquiétude
d'interrogation d'inconfort et je pense
qu'un chemin existe pour que les
sensibilités différentes je me suis
expliqué souvent y compris à votre micro
sur ce sujet pour que les sensibilités
différentes puissent se reconnaître que
nos concitoyens présents dans le pays y
compris issus de l'immigration peuvent
trouver un mode de vie en commun des
règles de vie en commun pour être
pour partager quelque chose de l'avenir
sans renoncer à ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui la communauté aucune
majorité pour voter ce texte puisque la
droite a déjà dit cette fois c'est clair
que pas une voix de droite ne la
voterait et toute la gauche est contre
aussi il faut utiliser le dernier 49-3
de la mandature je pense que ça ne
serait pas une bonne idée
sur la loi migration ou sur tout autre
loi sur la sur une loi il y a des lois
qui sont des lois de qui créent des
tensions c'est pas le moment aujourd'hui
précisément on verra dans quelques
semaines mais je crois que ça n'est pas
le moment de mettre sur la table des
textes qui qui sont inflammatoires qui
qui créent de l'inflammation oui un
report de cette loi mais pourquoi pas
plus tard
on ne peut pas éluder les
responsabilités qui sont celles des
gouvernants devant l'état de la société
française et du et du pays rien ne
serait pire que de mettre tout ça de
côté et de s'en aller en sifflotant en
se fichant et perduement de ce qui va se
passer par la suite la suite est
dangereuse le monde est dangereux
l'Europe est dangereuse et la France
n'est pas armée comme elle devrait
l'être parce qu'elle sait depuis
décennies au fond elle n'a pas affronté
les nécessités de l'éducation nationale
les nécessités vous évoquez
par la suite gros sujet je suis une
dernière question François Bayrou vous
avez été renvoyé devant le tribunal
correctionnel pour complicité de
détournement de fonds publics dans
l'affaire des assistants parlementaires
du MoDem Médiapart qui a pris
connaissance de l'ordonnance de renvoi
rapporte que les magistrates hypothent
notamment votre rôle central dans le
système frauduleux qui a été mis en
place
tout ça
ne tient pas un quart de seconde et
comme il y aura un procès maintenant on
le sait
tous les ou presque tous les députés
européens qui étaient accusés ont été
lavés et blanchis y compris mais la
dernière de semaine y compris Marielle
de sarnenez qui est morte il y a deux
ans
le les magistrats disent elle n'aurait
pas dû être poursuivre je vous dis qu'il
n'y a rien dans cette affaire qui soit
véridique et qui puisse permettre de
supporter une accusation
qui travaillaient aussi pour le parti a
aussi ils avaient été
accusation n'a été fondée sur des faits
et ça sera prouvé et quand vous êtes
totalement certain de votre innocence ou
en tout cas du caractère fallacieux des
accusations et bien vous n'avez pas
l'âme troublée et je ne l'ai pas merci
François Bayrou et bonne